I wanted to mention this because this
was also making the rounds yesterday
here's the article in your post it says
looks like Liam Neeson will not be
returning as a guest on The View the
Irish actor seven years old describes
his appearance on the ABC talk show last
week as embarrassing telling Rolling
Stone the entire segment left him
feeling uncomfortable during his
appearance on the show co-host Joy Behar
couldn't help but air out her longtime
crush on the taken actor in fact segment
included a montage of clips that showed
Behar making bizarre on-air comments
um niece and said I was in the dressing
room drinking a cup of tea turned the TV
up and I thought oh this will be great
we're talking about gun violence in
America I agree that it's an American
problem I go on stage and join the
ladies during the break and I was
congratulating the most on this
discussion that our segment starts and
it's just all this BS with joy and Liam
Neeson and having a crush uh and he says
I'm uncomfortable in those situations
and he said it was embarrassing
so that's how I thought I just want to
go back he feels embarrassed by it uh
and uh and here's the we'll play a
little bit of the clip of
these women hitting on Liam Neeson
please welcome Liam Neeson talk about
you so much I feel like you've been here
that's what I thought
you talk about it
[Laughter]
by you
I love it
it's Valentine from you today
happy belated Valentine's Day Liam X and
then I and I was like oh and I find out
you gave it to all of us
she will believe anything that you say
because it's no secret that Joy thinks
you're oh the hottest and the greatest
ever and
in case
in case there was any doubt we have a
few times she brought you up over the
years I think we have some videos I
would just like to have my ashes
sprinkled over Liam Neeson
there's room in my heart for Steve and
for Liam Neeson let's say
Liam Neeson right now are those
kidnapping movies that he does get me so
aroused I can't I can't even watch this
I can't even sit through this this is
this is like a human rights violation
this is this is I mean
you couldn't even do this to someone at
Guantanamo Bay this is like uh this is
and Liam Neeson yeah he's a leftist all
that he was complaining about because he
wanted to go talk about gun violence gun
violence is only an American problem
doesn't it right gun violence doesn't
exist did you know that did you know
that there's no gun violence anywhere
else in the world we're the only country
where people get shot uh it only happens
here so he's he's all that but even so
you got to feel some sympathy for the
guy I mean this is like can you imagine
a worse
uh nightmare I mean this is a worst
punishment this is this is worse than
than what happened to Donald dilbeck
last night uh having to sit with the
ladies of the view being sexually
harassed sitting next to Joy Behar being
not only sexually harassed by her in
person but then you have to sit there
and they put the reaction so they've got
the clips of her to make all these
creepy sexual comments about Liam Neeson
and then the reaction of Him Live having
to watch this while sitting next to her
it's just that's not right to do that
someone and this is sexual harassment
right
now I know we said in the opening the
whole uh uh imagine that the situations
were reversed saying it it gets lame
after a while because there are so many
double standards we spend all day on the
right pointing out double standards even
so uh this is we we should still note
obviously a double standard like you you
know if if we were to imagine a scenario
where it was a bunch of men on some kind
of talk show and a woman comes on and
it's the same sort of thing uh talking
about uh he uh he wants to be taken by
you and then and then I'll be playing a
montage of sexual comments made of it
would be everybody involved would be
fired that would be me too everyone's
fired
um and yet
one of the most grotesque women in the
country gets away with it
so
my sympathy does go to Liam Neeson
that'll do it for this portion of shows
move over to the members block if you're
not a member yet become a member and use
code wall should check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you Monday
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]